i think it's safe to say we have all
become a little more tech savvy during
the ongoing health crisis but dakota
johnson is still trying to figure it all
out as she needed a little help from her
boyfriend coldplay frontman chris martin
yeah as we know dakota and chris have
been dating since 2017 but they are
notoriously private about their
relationship now back in december dakota
told l-u-k
we've been together for quite a while
and we go out sometimes but we both work
so much that it's nice to be at home and
be cozy and private most of the partying
takes place inside my house
yeah the couple recently moved into a
12.5 million home in malibu and we're
getting a little glimpse into their life
at home as chris had to jump in and help
his girlfriend set up a zoom call for a
recent q a session during the sundance
film festival see you guys tomorrow bye
carlos
hey guys hey guys welcome and we also
have and her own screen um producer star
dakota johnson
hello welcome welcome
um
it's great to see the three of you
together
loving the film loving to see the three
of you all together on screen